to every move you make if the first
question you ask is how does this affect
my legacy my long-term legacy when it's
all said and done i guarantee the
currency will be there at the end i'd
much rather have a million friends right
now than a million dollars not even more
than a hundred million dollars the world
is changing we're more connected and
your legacy you're maneuvering your
decision-making process has to start at
your long-term legacy big picture always
wins what most people are about to do in
2022 in the nft space is make a lot of
short term money and [ __ ] up their
reputation what john knows because we
knew each other from early vine and web
two days is
people come and go
people come and go because most people
want the short bag
that's it they want the seven million in
two years buy house and chill i want the
process i would i want to go for it all
if you go for it all you're leaving
money on the table every day of your
life
the thoughtfulness of what you're going
to do to the audience matters and on
this one it's on the blockchain forever